à krems évoqué voilà je regarde toujours
le site de canard plus tard on va tous
mourir
c'est sûr qu'à vous enfilez tous les
jours
c'était moi
déjà tiré dessus c'est
mais ont tiré par unis à l'autre
où est-ce qu'ils sont tous pensé j'ai
c'est de les appeler mais y'a pas
tonalité regarde toujours rien j'en
attire depuis dix ans peut-être
quelqu'un enlever tous les passants du
coin le fait de penser différemment on
après supposer qu'il ya un fou qui tire
à tout va c'est peut-être autre chose
personnes dans le centre de madrid
ça ne dit rien la situation est critique
rihanna qui appartient cette mallette
seul tu ne sais pas que toute la ccin
est parmi nous et non pas de riz non ce
qu'on est en train de dire c'est qu'on
est déjà mort
j'ai peut-être une autre explication
croyez moi je ne vais rien dire
et si on avait été tous enlevés
[Applaudissements]